florida attorney general ashley moody
joins me now um madam attorney general
when did you learn of this
i learned of it when the rest of the
public learned about it laura and it is
an unprecedented move i think so many of
us have watched as the credibility of
our
fbi has been chipped away at over the
years we're just waiting for this this
institution to be rebuilt into that
institution of respect and independence
and and faith and and today is is a very
shocking day
not just for me but for many floridians
and americans
well people are gathering outside of
mar-a-lago in support of president trump
this never happened in the history of
the republic
we have never
arrived at this point where a succeeding
administration
has sought to
criminally
investigate uh a previous administration
of a president who's probably gonna run
for president again
uh
so they were upset when
they were upset when trump was saying
lock her up remember at all the rallies
the media was oh you can't say it's
horrible
what are they doing
there's no concern about any of this
though today is there
well you didn't see people rushing into
hillary clinton's home when there were
allegations that she had classified
information in her emails
you know i think people are just
expecting that the fbi and the
department of justice i mean i was a
former federal prosecutor i now am the
attorney general but i used to be a
federal prosecutor and you expect that
the fbi will treat
everyone the same every case the same so
that the american public can have faith
in this institution and i you know when
i have done anything that is has any uh
significance where folks may doubt
because i'm one party and you may there
may be an investigation related to
something you know you have to be
transparent and while this search
warrant in many cases they are sealed i
would urge this to be unsealed the
affidavit that supports it be unsealed
that the fbi issue a statement
immediately about what supported this
what types of charges or crimes they
expected the evidence to show that they
found
this is
really astonishing laura and i think for
the integrity of this institution there
needs to be immediate transparency yeah
well considering it they're supposedly
so worried about threats to democracy
they want to short-circuit democracy by
taking someone off the field that's it
to just people watching this tonight
that's what it looks like so while they
grandstand about democracy and
preserving democracy what's this
this is not what we expect from um from
the united states of america but your
boss governor desantis
sent out this tweet writing the rate of
mar-a-lago is another escalation of the
weaponization of federal agencies
against the regime's political opponents
while people like hunter biden get
treated with kid gloves now the regime
is getting another 87 thousand irs
agents to wield against its adversaries
banana republic
well i think he captured that right the
next the next move is
auditing of americans who disagree
final thoughts here well governor
desantis used to be a federal prosecutor
as well we share that in common and you
would expect there to be subpoenas if
there was
any suspect of classified information
requesting documents as has been done in
these similar cases not 30 fbi agents
rushing in on a search warrant it is
certainly unusual and i tell you what
the charges if there are any the
allegations
this better be a rock solid case to
wreck
whatever respect there is right now for
the fbi
well i think people across this country
are wanting full transparency but i
wouldn't hold your breath madam attorney
general thank you hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else